we're taking calls at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50
we're gonna go next to our caller from
the five-one-six-- area code who's
calling today from 5 1 6 hi David's me
James yeah what's going on James where
you calling from I'm from Long Island oh
great what's gonna so in my time being
involved with politics I've kind of
flip-flop from leftist to conservative
wow I think I finally found I kind of
finally found my spot as a social
democrat very much in line with your own
views Wow so well let me let me find out
about that when you were left before you
were right before you were a social
democrat how left were you um I was very
I was kind of a political but my family
was all very democratic so I kind of
just stuck with them um I really the one
issue for me that kind of stuck with me
was gay rights because I had family
members were gay and just to seed once
I'd be very much in favor with gay
marriage that's what kind of I was like
if that's the side that's gonna make
that's gonna treat them like human
beings
that's us I don't want to be on right
and then then I need you become
conservative in that middle period so
after the 2016 election I thought oh I
have to like really see if I can figure
out that I know what I'm talking about
when I'm talking about things and I went
down the YouTube rabbit hole I started
listening to people like ben shapiro and
steven crowder Wow and I thought their
arguments kind of clicked with me but
over time they kind of fell flat when I
started to look at other viewpoints and
then I found your channel I found other
liberal outlets and again I found my
spot is social democrat I think wow so
what you're saying is that you in your
apolitical sort of left-leaning
household you were sort of left-leaning
by default you then got sucked into a
right-wing YouTube echo chamber
including ben shapiro and steven crowder
which pulled you to the right but then
at some point after that channels like
mine and others were able to deprogram
you from the right-wing indoctrination
yes to the point where yesterday i
actually became a member of the david
pakman show Wow
Wow this is an incredibly completely not
staged and planned phone call yeah no
I'm completely sincere um but so the
reason I called is that the one thing
that's kind of stuck with me from
conservatism is the Second Amendment and
gun control okay um I want it to be
harder for irresponsible and mentally
ill people to get guns through whatever
means whether it be background checks or
training yeah a gun registry or
something like that good but the one
issue that I haven't heard a good
rebuttal to or a debunking of is the
whole domestic tyranny argument right
where an armed populace the only thing
that can fully prevent the tyrant from
taking control and I was just wondering
if you could give me your thoughts on
that argument if you disagree with it
yeah I do disagree with it I mean listen
at its face if you if everybody unless
you're making the argument which even
Ben Shapiro go check out when I debated
ben shapiro about this on my channel on
idea unless you're making the argument
that just regular citizens should have
access to all of the same firepower that
the military and the government and the
Department of Defense have individuals
with the firearms that are allowed to be
purchased are not going to be able to
prevent the government tyranny that they
claim to be afraid of
I just don't actually believe that
that's a sincere argument that most of
them are making some of them are
sincerely making that argument when ben
shapiro made it I don't think that's
really his argument in favor of guns I
think he's post facto coming up with
that okay so the way that my
conservative friends will rebut that
when I say that is that they'll say at
least we have a fighting chance like in
the same way that the American during
the American Revolution we were coming
against the greatest army in the world
but we had firepower we could fight
against them if people are completely D
armed unarmed they have no shot against
the government that wants to come in and
completely just take over no listen I
mean so a lot of times they will cite
the Jews being disarmed and Nazi Germany
and it's one of them another one
widely debunked example here's what I
would suggest instead uh if we all were
were to come together and say hey you
know what the real best way to prevent
government tyranny because listen in
Sweden nobody's talking about government
nobody's afraid of government tyranny
and demanding that everybody have
firearms to protect themselves in Norway
you don't hear about all of these
pro-gun arguments to protect themselves
from the Norwegian government becoming
tyrannical the threat of the American
government becoming tyrannical comes
from the reality that we have allowed
the Republican Party to suppress votes
via all of the voter suppression tactics
that they've put in place which is
extraordinarily authoritarian and the
authoritarian tendencies of the right
have allowed more and more authoritarian
leaders to be put in power like Donald
Trump the way to prevent even the threat
of that type of tyranny that they claim
they could hold off with with rifles and
ar-15s and handguns or whatever it's to
stop allowing the authoritarian
tendencies that we've seen to be
rewarded with electoral victories and
they're not willing to do that in fact
they're voting for a lot of those people
mm-hmm all right David I mean I really
appreciate the work that you do and I'm
happy to become a member just this week
thank you and thank you for taking my
call really appreciate it hope to hear
from you again great to hear from James
from Long Island if you're holding don't
hang up because we're taking a quick
break and then I'll be right back with a
few more phone calls right after so if
you're holding please don't hang up